OK, hi folks. Welcome
to session sec 342.
Threat modeling is code,
transforming your threat statements into attack trees.
My name's Danny. I'm a principal
security specialist with
our organization that's called AWS Industries.
I'm directly customer facing,
so I get the opportunity to work with customers
to understand.
Uh, specifically more around some of the
application security problems that they may be having,
uh, how to deploy that into the cloud, but also some
of the principles around application security,
threat modeling being one of the biggest ones that we tend to
talk about or that I talk about
with our customers.
I'm joined here today by Christian. Hi
everyone, my name is uh Christian Leo. I'm
a data scientist in uh AWS Security,
mainly specialize in compliance
information and building and training AI model
for security.
So, threat modeling.
Who here has heard of the 4
question frame or framework of
threat modeling?
OK, a couple of, couple of hands, so.
Really, when we talk about threat modeling, this was
a framework that was kind of coined
by Adam Shostack in the late 90s
of this mental model to help us
define and think about and kind of structure
how we how we work through the process of
threat modeling, and it's really comes down to four
questions. What are
we working on?
What can go wrong?
What are we gonna do about that?
And did we do a good enough job?
Now these questions, when we step through them one by
one, when it comes to an application, when it comes
to something that we're working on,
really helps us to define
risks,
controls,
and understanding the po the
potential threats to an application.
Now why do we do this?
OK, and when do we do this?
So when we think about the
design life cycle
of an application.
We can typically see
threat modeling.
Performed in the design phase.
If we do that, that means we get to identify
threats early, we get to iterate quickly on
early designs,
we get to do this in a way that helps us to find
the appropriate controls
to help reduce risk as we start to get to
the later stages.
We can also see this further down the pipelines as well.
We, the reason that we do this, even when it comes
to the deployment mode and even the maintenance
mode, is because things change, the threat landscape
changes.
You know, from one day to the next,
something may have happened, there may be a new vulnerability, there
may be a new threat actor group, there may be something
in place which
allows us to re-look at our
application, re-look at the threats that we orig
originally had defined, and then say,
do those things still apply,
given the new context, given the new information that
we have.
The reason that we try and do this as early as
possible
is because the cost of defect fixes
increases exponentially the further right we go.
So that's why it's one of the main benefits of doing it early.
We should be doing it often, as I said, as the threat landscape
changes, but the earlier we can do it,
the cheaper it is to add those mitigations.
No one wants to get to the point where they're
almost at the deployment phase, they're just
about to hit the button to production
and.
Something has happened and security says, hold on,
we need to, we've identified a threat.
This should have been fixed in the design phase, but it's not now.
We can't get this out into production because of
it's too high risk.
Right, so the earlier we can do that,
the cheaper it is from an effort perspective,
engineering perspective, and from a risk perspective.
So that's really what we mean by shift left.
But the reason that we do this as well
is because it helps us to keep pace with
risk. Right, we see that
risk goes up as you get closer
to production, right, as you are in production, as you are
in maintenance.
Obviously if you're in pre-production, it may not be
public facing yet, you may not be exposing
anything to users, and so therefore
the risk is lower. But as we get out there, as
we put things out on the public internet, we
start to see scraping
of live applications within
seconds.
And so we want to be able to understand that, we wanna be
able to have those threats in our
minds, have the appropriate mitigations
in place to help reduce that risk.
Now what are some of the benefits that we do this? The
top one is my favorite.
Whenever I do threat modeling workshops with customers,
we always bring in business,
we always bring in developers, and we always
bring in security into the same room.
How many times have those 3 different personas
been in the same room together in your organization?
Not that many.
It would be great if we could have that every single day,
and they could be having active participation
together. But actually when you
get to a threat modeling workshop, and you're
doing something on a whiteboard,
that allows us to start building strong relationships,
the business understands risk.
They have certain decisions or certain criteria
as to why things can go out into production, or
what risk they're willing to accept.
The developers understand the application,
they understand the code, they understand the intricacies
of the workload.
And the security understand the risks, they
understand the threats.
By combining those separate
and kind of unique perspectives, it gives
us a really powerful threat modeling activity.
When we run this as well,
we identify often
similar types of threats, similar types of risks,
and there could be controls that apply to
all of those things
that help reduce that risk. And so when we think
about this and when we do threat modeling and we identify
potential threats, there could be
controls that are often overlapping, let's say multi-factor
authentication.
That's gonna help us to reduce a number of
authentication type threats.
And so,
where we say actually, MFA is going
to show up on,
90% of the threats that we've identified, maybe
let's start there,
because that's gonna give us a good return on investment,
good value there.
It also becomes very helpful when we want to adopt new
technologies.
If we wanna adopt things like generative AI chatbots
into our workforce,
we wanna understand the threats to that.
What are the things that could go wrong?
How can we quickly allow the business
to adopt these new technologies, because
the developers, the people in that business, they want to
use these things.
So how do we, as a security organization, how
do we allow them to do that fast,
but safely and securely?
And threat modeling is a great way to do that.
And it also significantly helps us to
reduce review time.
At AWS we do threat modeling as part of
our application security review
process. We have a
program called the Guardian's Program,
which is a set of builders that are specifically
trained to act as
security advocates on their team, and they help
their teams do the threat modeling before
they get assigned an APsec engineer.
And what we found is that where
a threat model is applied,
and where a guardian is involved,
it reduces the time of an APsec review
by about 22, 23%.
That's a significant time saving.
And so if you and your organization are starting to
think about threat modeling, and you want to do
this early.
The security teams and you can go to the
security teams and say hey, we've done a threat model,
we've identified a number of threats
and therefore a number of mitigations
that's only gonna allow
the security team to review it faster,
maybe bar raise it a little bit, do
some, you know,
do some additional thinking and support and say have you
thought about these extra things, but really it's
gonna significantly reduce that time.
So at a high level, this is the
main framework that we tend to think
about, at least that, that I speak to customers about.
We've got our 4 questions, what are we building?
That's our scope decomposition, we
think about the scope, we think about our data flow diagrams.
What can go wrong?
We can think about threat intelligence input, that's really
important to help us
understand the current threats that are out there.
What are previous known
attacks from
advanced persistent threats
from other threat actor groups? What are the techniques,
tactics and procedures they've used
for certain similar types of workloads,
and could those things affect us?
We think about threat statements.
We'll talk about threat statements in a little bit in, in a bit
more detail, and we'll talk about attack trees as well.
And then we do the, what can we do about it, we understand
the risks.
Is this particular threat to our application
high risk, is it high impact? Is
it high likelihood?
And we define those things, this is where the business lens
comes into play.
Why is it risky? Why is it high risk? Is it
because it's going to compromise the confidentiality
of our data, the integrity of that data,
or the availability of the workload?
Different applications will
have different priorities for each of those.
If you're just a public facing site that
serves
content that is publicly available, maybe the confidentiality
is not too high,
but the availability is.
Maybe if you're healthcare,
then all of a sudden you're gonna err much more
on the side of confidentiality
over availability.
That then means we can identify controls.
For each of the things that we've identified that can go
wrong, how can we help to reduce that risk?
How can we bring either the impact down,
or the likelihood?
And then really importantly, we want to test the
effectiveness of those controls.
It's great to say, yes, we have this thing in place,
but have we actually tested it?
Have we gone through a penetration test, have we done
static testing, have we done dynamic testing
to confirm
that we think that that control
is sufficiently reducing the risk to
a level that we are happy with?
Super important.
So
threat statements.
Threat statements are a way, uh, it's, it's
essentially just structured grammar.
It's a way to write prescriptive threats,
to make it iterative and to make them very
useful.
And their structure really helps us
to define
things like priority, and things like impact.
So this is the main syntax that we'll talk through.
A threat source
with some prerequisites.
Can do something, some threat action,
that leads to some impact.
Which results in the reduction
of a required property or goal
of an asset.
Now a threat source can be an external actor, it can
be an internal actor, we've got different
threat actors there.
Prerequisites are just something that they need to have
access to. It could be someone with
no access, and that could be the prerequisite. Or it
could be someone with
administrative credentials, or someone with access to
an to the network.
They can go and do something that's going to impact
us in some way.
Now, as I mentioned, the applications
could have
or should have a required
property, like high confidentiality or high
availability, high integrity.
So when we talk about a threat that reduces that
thing, that's where
we put that into the goal,
and then we have an asset. Is it an S3 bucket? Is
it a.
EKS cluster, is there something else?
And so this syntax helps us to define,
allows us, the structure of it allows us to do
good analysis on things.
Right, which of these, as you start iterating
uh
these over time and time again, you can
say we've got 2025 threat, threat
statements.
How many of those are internal
threat actors, how many of those are external threat actors?
How many of those impact the confidentiality or the
integrity or the availability?
How many of those impact this specific critical
asset?
So having this structure makes that
analysis very easy to do.
So let's talk through an example.
An unauthorized user with the ability to scan
for open ports
can gain unauthorized entry to
the application instances.
Which leads to crypto mining on those instances,
resulting in the reduced availability of
the application.
OK,
so that first section is really the
what can go wrong, right?
Can gain unauthorized entry
to the application in instance.
We then have the impact side of things, which
leads to
crypto mining,
resulting in
reduced availability.
So that second section helps us to prioritize.
But what we found with threat statements
is
they can go further.
And we can do that in the form of attack steps.
And it's great, the threat statement's really great to help
us structures, to help us start thinking
about the what can go wrong, but the attack
steps are the how.
How can that thing really happen?
And it can happen in a number of different ways.
This is a set of attack steps
in order to get to that threat statement.
They perform brute forcing SSH or RDP.
They drop malware on the instance for local
privilege escalation.
They exfiltrate IM credentials over DNS.
They probe APIs with the credentials
that they have,
and they configure and create and launch
UEC2 instances.
And then they install crypto mining software
on top of that.
There could be 456
different other
ways to execute and to
get to the frame, the, the same threat statement.
And that set of different
attack paths
is ultimately what we get to for an attack
tree. Now,
attack trees are nothing new.
Schneier Bruce Schneier has been writing
about attack trees since 1999.
Right, as a way to provide a formal
and
excuse me, methodical way
of describing the security
based on a varying number
of attack paths.
And that's what Chris and I have really been
thinking about.
When I talk to customers about this,
I'm thinking, how can we go one step further, how
can we help them?
How can we help developers start thinking about this
thing? Developers may not necessarily
have the expertise
and the security mindset to think
about all the different ways
a threat statement can actually
happen across their application.
And so
we have been working on a tool.
That we call Threat Forest.
So this is going to be an open source
tool. This is gonna be something
that is available on GitHub samples
for everyone to go and use.
And what Threat Forest does
is it allows developers to execute this
on the CLI in their terminal or in their IDE.
It can point to a directory, and
it will help
run and create a set of threat
statements and attack trees
for them. We're
gonna demo this in just a minute, because
Chris, the brains behind the solution, is gonna
talk about all the science that has gone in
behind this. But let me, let me talk about the high level.
The two main phases that we have
our attack tree
generation. This is
gather some information.
Extract context from that
information, and start the attack tree generation,
and then phase two is the additional
threat intelligence alignment.
Now this really becomes important to us, because it
helps us understand
these things have happened in the past,
they are linked to existing and known
micro attack steps,
and so they have really good resources
and information associated with that.
Known throughout the groups that have used that sort
of attack step,
known. Mitigations and
controls that can help to reduce the risk of that attack
step from happening,
and so that's really phase two.
So diving in a little bit more, I'll let Chris
go through the various phases and
the, and the science behind this.
Thanks, Danny.
So let's zoom in on the first
phase, the attack 3 generation.
What we've built is a multi-aggentic
architecture that will
start reading your repository.
This repository may contain source code,
architecture diagram,
threat statements, and any piece of
information that will help threat forest
to actually automate
both threat modeling and the
regeneration.
So we start with an agent that
understands
the architecture of your repository.
It will start looking at what files exist
and it will guide
the future agents.
If any threat statements is provided, then
the parser agents will actually analyze
the threat statement. This can be a markdown
file, a PDF, or this can be actually
a file, an output of threat composer.
Threat Composer is another uh
CLI uh developed by AWS
to automate trend modeling.
If it's not provided, it will trigger
instead a specialized agent to
generate a threat statement file for you.
The second step is the content
extraction.
So once we have an understanding of what this
repository looks like,
once we have a threat statement in place,
then the agent will
start gathering the evidence required
to actually generate the attack
trees.
And then there is the 3rd step, which is
the actual attack tree generation.
And so
as a science person, I was, I wanted to
understand how we can leverage the
domain knowledge of SMEs,
security engineers
like uh Danny, like Anton
and other folks who contributed to develop
Threat Forest
and
science knowledge.
And so this is uh where
we implemented
a framework called DSPY.
DSPY claims to
code and not prompt so that
science and security engineers can collaborate
together to define a basic
prompt and then leverage science,
especially this novel algorithm
called GEPA, to
create optimal prompts
based on statistics.
And what GPA does is
using genetic Pareto, genetic
because it will spawn different
variations of prompts and
automatically using statistics,
find the optimal version. They won't
be stuck on a local optima, but will
find the very optimal version,
and this requires SMEs
to first create a first draft
of the prompt,
leverage strength agent, which
is energetic framework that we use in
production at AWS.
And generate traces, so
reasoning steps of the agent, the
tool executions, input and output,
and then have SMEs actually review
those traces and score them and provide
textual feedback
that then GAA will use
to
perform something called reflective prompt
optimization.
And this is an iterative step,
step that we took and uh
um we ran a bunch of times until
we were satisfied with the prompt.
The output of this is the actual final prompt.
They will be visible in the repository.
The second phase is
threat intelligence alignment.
Threat intelligence alignment
starts with an attack tree that we
generated in the previous phase,
and now we want to match
every step in the attack tree, every
node
to
techniques, to the TTPs, so
tactic techniques and procedures.
Uh, specifically for the first release,
we will be using the enterprise attack matrix
by Miter. Which we pre-index
as a graph,
and then an inference time,
once we generate every node in the
attack tree, we'll be able to encode
the node
and retrieve the most similar
attack step, technique by Miter.
And something important here,
I don't know if you're familiar with embedding models,
this is what we're using for the encoding,
but they tend to be smaller
than the classic LLM trained for
text generation.
And so
one important thing when choosing
the embedding model is that
will the embedding model have
knowledge about security?
Because something that can happen is that depending
on the choice of their embedding model.
The many model may not have been exposed on security
data and uh if we're asking
does this attack step.
Match a certain technique,
you may get a random number.
Why? Because the many model does
not know what an attack step is, or
you may get something very similar because it's
recognizing that this is a cybersecurity
domain. And so
We are using specialized
security embedded models.
Um, the default model that
Threat Forest provides is
Attackbird,
which is an embedded model fine-tuned
on the microt metrics, on
security data and security knowledge.
And to give you a comparison
about why the choice of the embedded
model is really important,
we created this, uh, uh, chart
where on the left column you can see the attack
step. These are attack steps that
will be generating during the attack 3
generation phase.
On the middle column we can see attack pair,
and the third column MPNET, which is
another embedding model for a general
purpose.
Something that you can see from the scores,
the similarity scores that are generated,
is that they are different, even
though we are trying to map the same attack
step.
And
the third column, the general purpose embedding
model, is less confident.
It tends to generate a lower
similarity score.
Whereas the attack bird is more confident
with its prediction, which is what we want
because we optimize prompts
of this attack 3 generator to
generate steps that are inspired
by micro-attack metrics or
other enterprise attack matrices.
And then the 3rd innovation
we created our own
local graph engine.
And we are representing TTPs
as graph
with the intent of in the future
supporting multiple TTPs
from spanning from Wiz, uh, Myer,
TTC, and so on, and merge
them together so that we can increase coverage.
And so once you want to actually
match
the your attack trees to multiple
mattresses, you will be able to do it,
considering multiple matriceses at the same time.
So now, then it will actually go through
a practical example using Thread
Forest CLI, OK.
We're gonna pray to the demo gods
and see if this works. I'm gonna need your fingerprints, sir,
to unlock your laptop.
Thank you very much, OK,
so. I
press this button.
OK.
It's a little
off, but that should be OK. Right,
so we're gonna run,
first thing we're gonna do is we're gonna run through our forest. OK, so
this is CLI
tool that we have here, it's going to
set this up and we're actually gonna start this from
scratch, OK, so you can see
the end to end process.
So the first step is
credential configuring, OK?
So when we do this, we're gonna,
we. At the moment for our
initial release, we support Bedrock.
We are going to support
other LLM providers, Anthropic,
Gemini,
a bring your own API key type
scenario, but for now we're gonna use Bedrock and we're gonna do
that with an AWS profile.
So, we're gonna choose our API
provider.
I'm going to hit Bedrock,
uh, we're going to choose a model.
So our suggestions at the moment are to
use something like Haiku for speed
or Sonic 4.5 for accuracy.
Opus gives us
more confidence and better structure,
but it just takes a little bit more time as well.
So I'm gonna go ahead and go for
speed for today.
I'm gonna go with Haiku.
And then I'm gonna use an AWS profile.
I can type correctly,
I'm gonna run this in East one, and the first
thing it's gonna do is it's gonna actually test our connection, just to validate
that it can access the,
the. Bedrock service,
and it can access that model.
So then what we have is
our first step, which is to generate
a well our kind of main workflow, which is to
generate attack trees and analysis.
And so in order to do this, it's gonna kind of take us through.
But we can see here on the configuration, which is
just the YAML file that gets created,
that we can, we can see the bedrock
provider, we can see the model ID, we can see the region,
we can see the profile that we're using,
we can see the embeddings model
that Chris spoke about, and we can also
see the TTP threshold.
And so this is the, this is the threshold
at which it will do that matching. So if it's
confidence score is above 30%
or 0.3, then it will map
that to a relevant uh TTP
from the microtack framework.
This is configurable.
If you want, you can say actually I only want ones
with really high confidence scores,
only map
attack steps to MITA if it's an 80%
or or above, you can, you can go and
actually configure that. But we're gonna keep that as
the default setting for now.
And so
What we do here is choose a
directory, OK?
Now, one thing that we have in this
is, or one thing that we recommend,
and the documentation as well that's that's in
the GitHub repository talks about
your preparing your project.
This is really important.
Having good documentation.
The more
good information we can give Threat
Forest about
the application, what it does,
what kind of things it serves,
what its objective is,
is it a healthcare application that's
going to be public facing and containing
super high sensitive patient information,
or is it a
static web page
that is going to serve, you know, just static content.
The more context you can give it
about the application,
as part of your,
in your directory, right, and this is gonna be local
files, things like PDFs, MD files,
images,
anything like that, so it's multimodal.
The more you can give it, the better the
output is going to be.
I'm sure we've heard this a number of times when interacting
with AI context is king.
It's very, very important to, to give
it good context, because you're gonna get
more accurate results.
Yes, you can absolutely have no documentation
or very little.
It will still go through this process,
but it will just give you more generic outputs
because it doesn't understand the application as
well. So, um
I'm gonna go over in the GitHub,
we're gonna have a number of sample
applications that you're gonna have an opportunity to play around
with. So in this case, this is actually,
uh, we're actually using the
threat composer file.
So Chris mentioned Threat Composer. Threat Composer
is an open source tool as well that we've
created to help you document your threat models, and
what this has is, what this does, it's got some
application information, uh, we've got a connected
vehicle solution here, we've got an architecture diagram,
we've got data flows,
uh, we've got assumptions, we've got an existing
set of threat statements.
We've also got a, a kind of another version of
this data flow diagram here.
Now this is something that you as a developer
can use day to day. This is using
the AWS toolkit extension in Visual
Studio code.
You can go in and interactively modify
um any of these threats. You can go create new
ones, and you can iterate on this directly
in your IDE. You can then commit this and it just
lives as a living threat model in
your, in your in your project repository,
and it can save in GitHub, you'll have,
uh, you know, the commit history
a part as part of that.
So we're actually gonna go ahead and use this,
so I'm just going to grab
this path, I'm gonna paste it in here.
And then the next question that Threat Forest is going to ask
you is, do you have existing threat statements?
OK. If so,
we'll, if so press yes and we'll continue on.
If not,
what Threat Forest does is it will generate
threat statements on your behalf in the same syntax
that we spoke about. And again, that syntax
is so important
to allow something like a model to
understand that syntax,
understand why it's important,
and then use that syntax
to create the threat statements, right, in,
in a way that becomes easier to analyze.
So I'm gonna go ahead and say yes because we actually have
our threat composer file, so I can just
copy the link to that file path
here. And again, because it's threat
composer, it just saves it as a JSON JSON format.
And then we are ready to go, so we are
going to review the configuration very quickly,
and we've got our full mode project threat
model, it's gonna generate the attack trees, it's gonna
enrich with micro attack map mappings
and add the mitigation recommendations. So I'm gonna go
ahead and say yes.
And so while this is working,
and hopefully it will go fairly quickly, and
what we'll see is we'll see how this
iterates through, we'll see the stages
that it's going through.
So the first one is actually looking at
threat composer file. It's quite a large file.
Um, we're trying to, we've, this is where we've got the
passer agents that Chris has mentioned,
where we, where we use that passer agent
to look through the file to only get some
of the specific things that it needs out of that. So
in this case, the first thing it's doing is looking for the threat statements.
So we can see here it's extracted 11
threats, 6 of those are high, 5
of those are medium.
Right, we can actually go,
go back into threat compose on the dashboard and we
can see, uh, the same thing.
Or high, medium and lows, right, so 11 threats,
6 high and and 5 high, high,
medium or lows.
Now the next thing it's doing is going to then.
Have our reposit repository analysis
agent look through that repository to get
the context.
So it's got some threat statements, it's going to look through
the files,
also look through the threat composer file as well,
for that additional context,
and it's going to start generating the attack
trees for us.
If you want, in the meantime,
um, we can actually look at logs.
So in here we can see two types, two
different types of logs, so we can see how things
are going,
and we can see that it's discovered in a series of files,
it's got our threat model file, it's going to
look through the,
uh, identify the model provider,
generate a number of threats, and extract
the high priority ones, and also look at strands
to take a look at what strands is helping
us do as part of the orchestration.
So as we do this, the repository
analysis agent has identified 12 different technologies.
Lambda, API gateway, Dynamo DB
has done this using the threat composer file
and that architecture diagram.
It's found 10 main
data assets, so things like S3 buckets,
EBS volumes,
and 8 possible entry points.
And so it's using that now to actually generate
the attack steps.
So as it goes through each of those different threats, so
the 6 high,
high severity ones, the next step is
then the mapping.
And this is where the embeddings model come in.
We've got the attack steps in their raw format.
It's now going to
go through each of the nodes in
that attack step and map it
to the embeddings model,
the attack boat embeddings model
that is stored locally.
And so it's going to map each one of these, and
then it's going to, to generate the, the final
output for us. So you can see that it's going
through that,
and then we can see what it does is
it creates a nice visual
dashboard for us, and it opens this up for
us, OK?
So we have, again, our exact summary.
11 total threats, 6 of which are high,
6 attack trees, 113 total
nodes.
The repository analysis agent gives us our
project information summary here. It's a connected
vehicle solution.
It's a server architecture type, it runs on
AWS.
It's extracted the industry sector,
and we've got a number of technology stacks in there
as well. And now
for the fun part, we have our high severity threats.
So each of these threat statements,
if you can see this, maybe I'll uh zoom
in
a little bit.
Each of these threat statements have come from the
threat composer file,
so we can see that syntax.
An internal actor with access to
the AWS to the AWS account
can deploy a lambda function that will use
existing execution role,
leads to unauthorized access to sensitive data,
resulting in reduced confidentiality of registration
status.
OK, so another
another threat statement using that syntax.
And then we can actually go in and view our attack trees.
So, for each of these threats.
Oh, I've zoomed out too far.
Let me zoom in a little bit.
OK, there we go.
So we can see
this is where the interesting stuff happens,
right, we can,
our attack tree gives us a start
point, which is our internal actor
with AWS account access
that has been extracted from the threat statement.
We then get down to a number of different
ways
in order.
Let me just
Zoom out for a minute, in order to get to our
goal,
and our goal down here at the bottom
is confidentiality breach of
the registration status.
Now, from a visual perspective, we can see
that there's a number of different flows in order
to achieve this.
Right, there's a number of different steps,
attack paths, in order to
get from
our initial objective.
Down to our goal,
and we can click on each one of these nodes
to look at what it's trying to do. So we've got reconnaissance,
so it's looking at existing lambda execution
roles,
identify sensitive data locations.
If we follow this one down, it's going to enumerate
I am roles with excessive permissions,
identify lambda execution role,
and, and each one of these, right, we've got
deploying malicious lambda functions, and so the point of
this is,
is that we've gone from a
fairly broad, high level threat
statement. Which is
something bad can happen with the lambda function
to a very specific
targeted steps of how that
thing can actually
get executed across our across our workload.
Which then means we can map that to MITA,
so we can see here, uh, this particular
one is
42% confident that it's mapped
to this one. Now obviously,
it's trying its best, right, as we get
more,
as we get, as we have more data that we're consuming,
we can start to see this, you know, the accuracy
of these, of these mappings go
up. And then what becomes
important is our mitigations,
right, because of this, we can now say,
uh, we can now look at some of the information that Mita
is going to give us
to help as a developer understand
why we need these mitigations in place.
And now as we expand this out, we can start to think
about how many of these mitigations are common,
how many of these things are, you know, repeat themselves
over different types of attack steps, maybe we
start there, going back to that benefit
that I mentioned earlier of
prioritizing controls and prioritizing mitigations.
So that's really it from, from a demo
perspective. I'll let
Chris talk through some of the science natural code
behind some of this as well.
Thanks Danny.
So
switching now to the actual
code, some of the things that you want
to look for and know when using
this CLI application is that
um the first time that you're
using it, it will create a do threadforest folder
for you. Uh, it will generate a graph.
Uh, the graph is stored as a JSO file
with nodes and a relationship.
Um, the use of a local
graph engine will make it
a stand-alone application. It doesn't need to rely
on, uh, third party,
uh, applications or graph database. It's also
much faster. The idea is that,
um, TDPs tend to be
smaller in size and so we don't need to rely
on, uh, um,
uh, proper graph database.
This is also where we'll be able to see
the embeddings that are stored, so
every time that uh you choose an embedded
model, that will automatically index
every node for the
um TTPs.
It will also create a dot EMV file.
Uh, I can actually show you the. EMB file
here because I'm using the WS profile,
so it's not a sensitive information per se.
Uh, but if you are using any other
API key, it will automatically show it to
you, so, uh, don't send it around.
And the config YAML file where it can
actually show what we're using,
attack bird, you will be able to also set
the uh TDP threshold.
In this case we're using 0.3. Uh, it's
leveraging cosine similarity, so the score
tends to go from -1 to 1. 0.3
is not necessarily low, but it's
not necessarily high, but you can change that based
on how confident you want to be in
the mapping.
And then, um, a bunch of sample
applications.
Something that on a code wise,
I want to focus on is,
um, the actual modules. So
the main entry point for this will be the
CLI,
but the actual core,
uh, module will be the orchestrator,
which is running all these multi-agent
steps. But before diving
into that, um, there is
the graph module where
we are using sentence transformers.
So sentence Transformers is a library
built on top of the Transformers
library from hugging face,
uh, and what this lets you use
is bring your own model.
So you can use any model existing
on hugging face.
Uh, and now pretty much every open source model is a hugging
phase, and if you wanted to use
your own model, for example, take this and
fine tune it with your own,
uh, data, you can do that.
Uh,
the next step is the graph builder.
So this is our own logic for
graph Builder. Something that you can see here is that
we leverage the micro Attack
in sticks format
and so, um, we will
turn every technique and mitigation.
Into nodes and one of the primary
reasons why we're also using graph
is that
considering that we always want to do traversal,
the complexity in when
doing traversal from a graph is linear
instead of a quadratic compared to relational
database.
And this is our actual graph, uh,
engine that will let us, um, store,
uh, behind the scenes. This is actually just using
Ampi arrays and ASource
to get the most similar,
uh, nodes, uh, but then we'll
probably make it more, a little bit more advanced as
we scale up involving multiple graphs.
And then this is the vector search function function
to run memory vector similarity
search. Uh, we also have
a visualization module which is, um,
what lets you generate the report
in HTML file,
but now let's actually dig into the
agent component.
So something that I specified
before is that we're using strands
agents. So if you're not familiar
with strands, it's an agentic framework
developed by AWS.
Um, it supports multiple model
providers. Um,
as of now we have an experimental mode
Gemini or LA, L L LLM,
LMA API,
uh, OpenAI and Atropic.
And uh uh the content extractor
uh relies on a base agent class and abstract
class uh with a bunch of signatures,
but its goal is to extract the
uh context and so we look for
files and automatically classify
them as architecture diagram,
as, um, rhythmi files,
source code, and so on, and they will help,
uh, this agent has actually access to
two different agents,
one that is the parser agent and the other
one is the threat generation agent.
Uh, the parser agent is used when
we, uh, have a threat statement file
or we have a threat composer file,
um, and so it's instructed to
extract existing threat statement
from a threat statement file.
The other one is the, uh, threat
generation agent, which instead we leverage the
information by the contact extractor agent
to create your own,
uh, threat statement file.
These agents are leverage, leveraging
three main tools by Strength agent.
Uh, so, um, as Danny
mentioned before, this is multi-modal. It's
multi-modal because we use the read
image uh tool byres.
This will encode, uh,
images, and then it will automatically
send a request to
your LLM provider, um, to
resonate over the image.
It will also be able to read files,
list directories, and it's also using, uh,
an editor tool,
um, to actually scan in
your repository,
create the three directory structures,
run in line search, fuzzy search, so
that if, let's say that you have a
very big file that wouldn't fit in the
context window of your agent,
then it's able to run a, um,
intelligent search within the file itself.
We actually uh run a smart
tweak,
uh, since the editor agent
by strengths is able to write
and create new files,
so we created a wrapper on top of it
so that we can uh
allow certain actions, for example, view
to create the three directories and find
line to, uh, start running a smart
search. So that uh
everything when you're running through a forest, you don't
have to uh run into the risk of
actually overwriting your files
or having
it access something that you don't want to
have it access to.
Anything that once you select
the path to the directory that you want to
scan,
the thread forest will only be able to read
the directory and it will only have read permissions.
Um, and then, um,
just to continue, we have the 3 generator
agent.
The 3 generator agent, uh, consume
is able to generate mermaid code,
uh, so it's been, uh,
prompt optimized on generating mermaid, and
then what we do behind the scenes is converting
the mermaid structure into a graph.
And uh uh and so this
is pretty much it. The CLI module
will actually be able to run the CLI
and is responsible to for the CLI
interactions,
uh, and then models will contain um
the data signatures.
And uh uh in utils instead we can
be able to run the uh
WS validator and uh and so on. In
prompts you'll be able to see actually the prompt they've been
generated using uh DSPY
uh with GA.
uh, in the future we'll be able to
release the specific module
that we are using to run
DSPY.
Um, and how we can optimize
with the intent that, um, if you have
a specific data set and specific needs and you
want to customize thread for as to
your specific data, you will be able to
optimize,
uh, the prompt and use the collaboration that I was
talking about between, uh,
scientists and engineers.
Um, now everything,
everything of this is, um, available
on GitHub.
Um, we made it available right before this
talk, so, uh, then I think
you have a, yeah,
a QR code.
Cool. Couple of other things I think just in
general that we that we could talk about for the
for the last few minutes is
um some learnings, some learnings that we've
done. So one around the prompt is, is really
important. When we first started creating
this,
it was a fairly
big prompt,
one or two big agents,
a lot of reliance on
the LLM
to do a lot of the heavy lifting and intelligence, right? So
it was a big prompt that says you are
cybersecurity expert,
read through all of my files.
Generate some threat statements, generate a
series, a series of attack steps, you know, using
that context,
whereas we found, and we found a lot of inconsistency,
you know, we live in a non-deterministic world these
days, so we found it was hard to kind of
get structure, get consistency out of this,
and so that's why you see, you know, we've got 12,
between 12 and 15, or, or maybe a few
more very specific targeted
prompts
for very specific targeted.
actions and agents
we've got a number of agents, a number of prompts.
This kind of
small modularization of the prompting
has allowed us to
be very targeted and get very good
structure and output and control
the outputs of what we're expecting
from the LLM, do some validation on that thing
before moving on.
OK, so that's, that was a really important thing
that that we started to learn through.
Just a couple of other things to
show quickly is.
We also have uh the outputs
of this is not just
the
nice visual dashboard in HTML that we've
created, and we also store all of this
data and provide all of this data in it's kind of raw
formats in MD
and Jason.
So this is the,
the high level.
Report that gets created uh
in an MD file
right so we see again a lot of the same
information, technology stacks, security objectives,
analysis results, each of the high severity
threats. This is just the ID that comes from
threat composer.
Um, we have our generator attackies, and then
we've got our kind of recommendations
here. And then for each,
oops,
let me close that one.
For each of the attack trees, we then also form,
as Chris mentioned, format this in Mermaid,
so it's a slightly different way of visualizing it, but
again it's slightly nice, um nice views,
nice visuals here
to actually get to this mapping, and then we see each
a little bit more detail on the micro attack mapping.
We see the similarity scores, we see mitigations
in here.
And then a little further down
we have.
Uh, just, yeah, some of that more attack
path analysis.
And then we also keep things in state just
in case there's any errors or
anything like that, so or if you do
introduce new.
New threats to your threat composer file, it'll look
at the state,
understand
there's one new, one new threat, it's a high threat.
We're gonna go and create an attack for you based on that rather
than creating,
you know, another 6 other ones that are,
you know, that end up being duplication, and
then the whole thing is then just stored in a, in a large
Jason format as well in case you want to do
anything more programmatic with this.
Another example as well to show you, uh, so
we ran this one earlier, this is just one of the other sample
applications that we have in the repository. This one
didn't have any, any threats
in here already, right, so we just had
an overview of the application
and an image
that was used.
And so this is kind of the, the other mode,
this is the, the,
the generation of the threat statements
itself.
And so we see here.
That it's actually gone through using this context and is generating
threat statements for us.
So in case you are at a point where you actually, you
haven't started yet, that's fine, you don't
have a threat model,
we'll help you create that threat model and then this
is used
as input into the next stage
4 for the attack regeneration. And then
we can see here it's broken down using our
syntax as well.
Anything else that you wanna cover?
You know, just the emphasis also on the
um open source and local fact
that we played out
so that um most of the times if
you're running a threat modeling you want to make sure
that nothing gets sent out on the cloud
or
you have full control over your data
uh and so this is uh the reasoning behind
some of our um assumptions
of having open source deployed in your own
environment running local embedding
models.
Uh, and reliance as
for the genetic component, uh, Pedrock
that you can trust,
um.
Um, and you have full
control over the data, you can see the prompts
and you can just see all the code. There is nothing
that is not visible in the Gita repository.
OK, so wrapping up
a little bit.
Just an overview of where kind of threat forest
or the coverage that we have mapping back
to our framework,
OK, it can do everything apart from
actually test the controls for us and do
the risk analysis,
right, so, so we are
allowing it to help with the scope
decomposition, really the, the what are we building?
To be fair, Dire Forest isn't really doing that for
us. That's, that's a you job, that's
a developer job
that has to create the documentation
to give us
that information. Again, the more we can
give it, the, the better context
we can give it with that scope decomposition, data
flow diagrams and and whatnot,
the, the better you're gonna get
or the better output that you're gonna get.
But we have our threat intelligence input. We've got a mitter attack
framework
right in our next version that we're gonna be releasing,
we're gonna have an
additional input from the AWS
threat technique catalog. If you haven't seen that, go
check that out. That is specific steps
related to AWS
TTPs, so tactics, techniques and procedures
that are also mapped to MITA, but these are very
specific to.
Um, tactics used that we see or
our, our,
our customer instant response team, the cert
they see
being used in AWS environments, right?
So it's very, very specific to AWS
environments. So that is a really, really great resource
that we're gonna be consuming as well. And then any
other third party open source,
um, matrices that that are available,
we're gonna start to consume those as well.
We've got our threat statement creation, we've got our attack tree
development. Now,
attack trees.
Can also be used for other things,
right, I've been thinking about this more and more as, as we've
been creating this.
Initially this started out as a, we want
developers to be using this, and we absolutely do want developers
to be using this, we're trying to make it as friendly for
them to use in the IDE to use in,
in, in their, in their, in their CLI.
Another really interesting use case of attack trees
is scoping
and defining test cases for penetration testing,
and automated penetration testing.
We're starting to see more
agents in that, in this space. We, we,
we announced one in preview, in public
preview yesterday, our AWS security agent,
where it can do penetration testing against an
application. And so
as we're starting to see those, there could be really
interesting overlaps where it takes some specific
context of your application,
generates the threat statements, generates the attack trees,
and then that can be used as inputs for another agent
to start simulating those attack trees
on our behalf.
OK, so another pretty interesting use
case as well.
The other use case that I've been thinking about is from a
defensive side.
If you're a security operations center and you're a
defensive
organization, you want to maybe think about
generating these detectories,
maybe, and then looking through them and saying which
ones of these would we be able to detect?
Do we have the right logs in place to look for land
for execution role,
uh, bypasses or compromises, or the,
the misuse of those?
Do we have the detections in place to look for
these types of things and these very specific tax
steps? Do we have the logs in place? Do we have the
detection use cases? Do we have the alerting,
do we have the run books? So it could be really
interesting ways to stress test some scenarios
for your defensive blue teams.
That threat intelligence really kind of helps us to bridge
the gap with how, OK, so we see
that these industry frameworks
are there because they are a collection
of previously of known attack
steps, right, from known
threat actor groups.
So that gives us
some understanding that these things are viable.
They have happened in the past.
There are certain threat actor groups which typically use
these things more.
That again allows us if we're in a more
defensive mindset, we may be able to say,
given our industry,
given the types of, you know, our position in the market.
We are usually susceptible to
attempted attempted attacks from these
sorts of threat actor groups that are known for targeting
these sorts of industries.
We can go and simulate these particular attack
steps based on
known
micro attack steps.
And then the graphical side of things, right?
As in through, through graphs, these knowledge graphs
allows us to capture these relationships
in a really structured way.
Right? And so having these TTPs as graph, which
is just a, a more scientific way of calling
an attack tree,
means that we can start to normalize and
start to understand the different ways these
things are going uh interact with each other and the
relationships between them, and having those
relationships between them means that it
helps us to improve accuracy when we're when
we're mapping to, to the microattack framework.
And so, as Chris mentioned, we are happy to
say that Threat Forest is available on AWS
Samples GitHub,
um, as of today.
So that QR code should take you straight there.
We encourage you to use it,
clone it,
play around with it, look at the code, run
it, give us feedback. We
really wanna hear feedback from you, and you
can, you can connect with us, uh, through,
you know, through a GitHub issue or even via email.
We wanna know
how it's working for you.
And what you'd like to see,
OK, so that's available uh there on,
on GitHub. We recommend starting with
the sample applications,
right, there's a lot of good documentation in there, and
the sample applications are there to help
you test so that you don't have to test it on something
that you may be working with.
Got links here as well for an overview of
GPA that the the framework that Chris
mentioned earlier for our reflective prompt
optimization and obviously we've got the the
MITer attack framework here too.
Any closing remarks?
Just, uh, stay tuned because
we provide many updates. We may release,
uh, the research and
the science,
um, that get into creating the forest,
um, and also following up with the
specialized embedding models as well.
OK,
thank you everyone.
Please fill out the survey in the app. Hope
you enjoyed that, we'll be around for some questions as well.